crowd funding campaign you have to be
very you know leader in a very
charismatic person and a team player but
there's a couple of real components that
you need you really need your social
media type of sort of magician they're
very important number two you really
need sort of like the programming
director because there's so many tunnels
you are sending out content to it it's
Twitter or this so that it's almost like
running a radio station and then thirdly
you need someone who will do some press
out reach you know to reach the press so
I mean either it's yourself doing it all
or it's two people but I did but there's
really like three components to it you
know they really need one person who is
really running the social media one
person who is really run trying to talk
to the press and a third person who is
in charge of just in a costly tweeting
and sending content whether it's videos
are you know uploading videos in a
blogging reblogging and ascending
broadcasting out you know different
skill sets and I have none of them I'm
learning all of this myself you know I
don't even type I mean you know it's not
that I mean I'm I'm techy I have all the
other things but it's just too like
there's so many people you know from
high school but their kids so one of my
movies like oh my god I don't even know
they are I'm gonna go you know they find
you and I a lot of people have the
energy for it I don't know how to do
that yeah I think a lot of you know the
young generation has it very much sort
of ingrained I think from the texting
you know and being on this that they
have it it's almost like part of their
brains that you just flow that's very
comfortable with it I mean honestly for
me to write it tweet it's like writing a
piece of poetry or like or like haiku
poem you know I spent hours just trying
to write a little tweet which some
people just tweet out instantly they can
do thousand a minute you know for me to
write a little blog post that's a
nightmare it's like writing an essay
that takes away to work you know and
some people just can't blog in like left
and right constantly just flows out of
them so I
so I guess it's but its necessary and if
I call it an evil that's that's a
negative connotation but it's a
necessary thing yeah you have to have
someone that loves to do it that you
have to love it to do it well
you